i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight thanks for
joining us
wreck it radicals that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
the economy is um
it's doing doing fairly well um it's uh
we expect growth to be
to be solid this year for the first time
since 2016
the treasury department is planning to
pay down the national debt issued to the
public this quarter we recovered faster
than projected
nice try guys but by any objective
measure america across the board is
facing some of the most severe
challenges in our nation's history
in china we have a dangerous
geopolitical threat
there's a war raging in eastern europe
the dow dropped
1063 points today
inflation is outpacing wages
our industrial base is crippled
and of course we're 30 trillion dollars
in debt
now this is a time when america needs
leaders who can begin at least to tackle
these major issues one by one in a
practical and sophisticated way
but unfortunately with team biden we
have a fundamentally frivolous and
unserious group of people
our president is a man incapable of even
saying the word plutocrat let alone
having the type of executive leadership
and judgment that we all need and
deserve
now nobody even thinks that at this
point biden does anything anymore
essentially his staff escorts him in and
out of events and they hope he avoids
you know grabbing at the air
when he's supposed to walk off the stage
his team should have surrounded him
though with a cabinet of experts who
could do the parts of the job that he's
obviously manifestly incapable of doing
and with such a weak president he really
needed a vp who was smart enough to earn
the trust of the voters
someone who could do the job if she had
to that's kind of the whole point
kamala harris though is a laughingstock
who laughs too much
more parents are seeing the value of
educators when they had to break their
kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
do you have plans to visit the border
not today
a friend in need is a friend
i i think that was my favorite laugh of
all
now instead in in kamala biden's you
know
just surrounded by another person who
can't do the job and he's surrounded by
scores of incompetent people who live
each day to please
maybe the panel on morning joe
not one of these cabinet secretaries was
chosen on merit
think about mayor pete south bend
indiana he knows nothing about
transportation
what's the biggest way that
transportation has been permanently
changed by the pandemic you know we
think transplants and automobiles but
what about bike scooters wheelchairs for
that matter
and a cool scooter for my birthday dad
my orcas knows nothing about the border
we inherited a broken and dismantled
system that we have effectively managed
an unprecedented number of non-citizens
seeking to enter the united states
is it just me or does he always seem
scared
yellen might be the most economically
illiterate treasury secretary we've ever
had
when do you expect the inflation to get
back to the you know two percent range
well i expect that to happen next year
um monthly rates of inflation have
already fallen substantially uh i expect
improvement uh by the end of by the
middle to end of next year
here's the rule of thumb if you can't
find the prompter or the camera it might
not be a good time to be the treasury
secretary now our military leadership
it's also embarrassing i'd call them jv
but that's an insult to all the great jv
teams across the country
i want to understand white rage and i'm
white and i want to understand it we're
clear-eyed about the challenge that
china presents
but china's not 10 feet tall
this is america
good argument
jennifer granholm what does she know
about energy
department of energy is really committed
to increasing energy affordability
energy resilience securing the clean
energy supply chains that are needed to
re to
reduce our reliance on unabated fossil
fuels and increase our energy
independence
someone wrote that for her well they
were all chosen for their relative
abilities to appear on liberal tv shows
and appear politically correct
so biden's diversity equity and
inclusion ambassadors is what i'd like
to call them
now the angle you might remember
begged the administration to switch
these people out early on and put in
truly experienced and pragmatic
individuals of talent
every single person on his economic team
should be fired this means treasury
secretary janet yellen buh-bye energy
secretary jennifer granholm never should
have been there in the first place mayor
pete at transportation he can bike away
almost all of his economic advisers
should go
and on what basis should jerome powell
be
nominated as fed chair by the way
no basis now the white house needs to
admit that they made mistakes a lot of
them
and then they can begin to move forward
maybe to begin repairing what they in
fact wrecked
but the reality is when you really think
about it let's
all be really candid in this moment of
distress for america
they don't care what happens to you
they think gas prices should be higher
they're always jealous of europe's high
gas prices i just went to france and
their gas price is much higher remember
that conversation you had with your
cousin
they think countries should be stronger
than ours and that we should be weaker
they think schools should be used to
promote radical social agendas and they
think government funds should be
distributed to those groups who are
likely to help the democrats
they think criminals deserve a break and
that you never do
and for the next six months they're
going to scream and wail like you heard
elizabeth warren the other day about
everything except stuff that will
actually help you and your family
so as the dow was plummeting today this
is what cnn was locked on
lordy there are more tapes newly
released audio reveals house minority
leader kevin mccarthy discussed actually
removing donald trump from office
melanie how many more tapes could there
be out there
well if you're kevin mccarthy you're
hoping there are zero more tapes
they'll encourage people to riot and
smash things use mail and ballots stuff
the ballot boxes of course they'll do
that as well one of the most shameful
things i think that's happened in the
past 50 years
is that
so many who spent their careers
pretending to be republicans
have abandoned the supporters who voted
for them or read their lousy articles in
the first place
rather than working to replace this
doddering fool with an america first
leader
they'd rather prop up radical
incompetence
their hatred of trump trumps what's best
for america
people were betrayed
by
a sitting president of the united states
now we gather
due to a selfish man's injured pride
thanks mitt
now remember when biden claimed he was
just a guy from scranton who cared about
the little people
he sees the world
from park avenue
i'd see it from scranton who's looking
out for the average person out there
people i grew up with in scranton that's
a lesson i've never forgotten
when i grew up surrounded by a lot of
hard-working folks
in scranton pennsylvania
we're paying six bucks a gallon for gas
joey
well now the little people will find
it's going to be harder to get a job pay
their mortgages afford groceries even
forget saving for a rainy day they're
going to need that money to pay off
their bills sending their kids to
schools maybe that teach what the kids
really need to know to be successful in
life
their dreams are being dashed one by one
and the biden crew couldn't care less
they think they'll quiet your concerns
by hyping the roe reversal or by making
up fake things about ron desantis
as long as these people remain in power
our lives and the country we love will
continue i'm sad to report to
deteriorate
nothing will really improve all that
much until they're beaten at the ballot
box so badly
that they're going to think long and
hard about trying such nonsense again or
at least not for a very long time
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else